summit later this month
uh let's analyze a little bit what's
been happening here we can bring in sami
puri who's author of russia's road to
war with ukraine joins us live now from
singapore so something i think you've
been listening into what's been said um
so vladimir putin's saying that russia
is coping with what he called this
the financial aggression the sanctions
just how stretched would you say russia
has been
by the sanctions put on it because of
its invasion of
ukraine yeah i mean it's uh quite a
surreal thing to watch vladimir putin
standing in vladivostok which is about
as far as you can get in russia away
from ukraine
now i think the stress that russia has
faced has been intense its economy of
course is now more cut off from the
western from many global markets than at
any point since the end of the cold war
and in some respects the way that the
war in ukraine has gone in russian uh
russia's subjection to sanctions means
that russia's economic fate is sealed it
has to become an asia facing eastern
facing economic power or it will
economically perish and that i think
means that this eastern economic forum
speak by putin is especially significant
and it's also significant because uh he
talks about a multi-polar world but
there aren't that many other leaders of
his level attending in person so i think
you know russia's uh economic edifice is
is i think a very precarious stage i
think is what i say
right
as i said the
chinese number three i believe is there
lee zhanchu head of the country's
legislature
due to have talked with putin a little
bit later could set up further talks
with the chinese premier down the line
later this month
clearly that relationship with china is
is critical for russia
it's absolutely critical and in fact uh
russia chinese bilateral trade has been
rising in previous years that's
accelerated by uh the conditions around
the ukraine war
and xi jinping and putin will uh will
meet eventually in uh in the g20 summit
in indonesia which is in november so if
they're able to meet bilaterally as
you're saying in advance of that uh
scheduled meeting in november that would
be very significant
i suppose the next question is where
would such meeting take place would
president xi come to russia would putin
travel out to china that in itself will
be very significant but this is yet to
be confirmed but i do think it's
important that the chinese set their
number three and not a more senior
official to this particular uh forum
right so if china aren't on that if
china is critical to russia how critical
is russia to china
well uh everyone will remember that
jinping and putin met at the beijing
winter olympics on the 4th of february
this year just before russia began this
invasion and they spoke of a deep and
enduring friendship they should have
documents around this
but in the seven or eight months since
then russia has probably become
something of a bit of an embarrassment
to china in the sense that the war in
ukraine has not gone as well as uh
russia almost certainly would have voted
and wanted to but nevertheless uh china
and russia do find each other to be
extraordinarily important because both
countries are experiencing different
degrees of sanctions from the usa and
from the west so in some respects they
have to band together but it is a bit of
a marriage of convenience between the
two of them of course there is the
obvious point to have a huge land border
and one final point on that which i
think this forum really speaks to is the
infrastructure development between china
and russia for example the power of
siberia pipeline and all sorts of
associated projects with modernization
of vladivostok as a port its ability to
take in cargo all the things we're
hearing about air travel in this region
obviously russia is going to put a lot
of focus now on the development of the
eastern side of the russian territory so
its trading potential with china can
actually match the the sort of the
wanted ambition to i think double
chinese russian bilateral trade which
both president xi and putin have spoken
about as an ambition to their countries
and one final thought samir putin also
talked about the possibilities of of new
markets and relationships the
possibilities of entering or at least
expanding the markets entering iranian
and middle eastern markets what about
that
hugely important and i think one of the
critical features of of the last six
seven months are the countries that
haven't sanctioned russia because they
are keeping russia afloat and they are i
think speaking to this grand vision that
putin presents in this speech of a path
to a multipolar world iran is critical
turkey as well uh putin mentioned turkey
with the great deals critical
but if we look at the attendance of this
war i think it's armenia mongolia
myanmar in terms of in-person attendance
by prime ministers i think russia has
got quite a long way to go to securing
uh its sort of return to
prominence in the international stage
given what's happened over the course of
2022
fantastic thanks for that analysis and
perspective i do appreciate that that's
samir puri speaking to us from singapore
as president vladimir putin addresses
the seventh eastern economic forum in
vladivostok in eastern
russia now